hey guys I'm Ryan Wright let's to be
[Music]
crazy we're going watch the trailer
today for The Evil Within every last
bullet trailer for PS4 Xbox One we watch
some of this I'm excited for this game
this game looks awesome I play this it
does look terrifying have you seen any
of the trailers no and I'm excited well
all you got to know is it's about a
detective who gets into some bad [__]
cool and it's bloody and gory and
terrifying makes for a great story
there's guns I think there's guns I
would assume with every last bullet
being the name of the trailer yes Dan
does deduction very well you could be a
detective I got to cry you could Sol
yeah why is this thing so [__] big
Jesus Christ genetics my penis genetics
I did it and just like anything else I
left Ryan unsatisfied
oh hella bird all right we're going to
going to watch the trailer now play the
trailer blood and gore intense violence
in [__] language
cool oh oh
hiang
[Music]
oh oh
nope NOP nope
[Music]
no
oh The Evil Within the disturbing new
experience from the father of survival
horror Shinji makami takes us into the
Twisted world of detective Sebastian
castios as he unravels the horrific
details of who or what is terrorizing
Crimson
City what the
[Music]
hell burn
it with
fire weapons and ammunition are a
luxury when you cannot always depend on
when confronting the haunted out of
ammo ouch oh God having to make your
disposal can turn what should have been
a quick kill into a room for your
life staying hidden in the shadows May
save your life and give you the upper
hand when ammo is running low
oh improvising is survival is living
nightmare of sinister creatures
unforgiving environments and lethal
traps meant to capture M and
kill I saw that
wire you'll need to be creative and
figure out how to turn obstacles into
assets that's pretty cool wow sometimes
your enemies may appear to be dead it's
best to make absolutely sure oh God damn
it throughout the world there Sebastian
can access a safe haven known as the
Asylum you're always welcome here it is
in this mysterious place that he can
upgrade his weapons abilities and
inventory these upgrades will help you
with your survival without them you're
as good as
dead to solve the mysteries of a city
where everything has gone wrong you'll
need to survive first and formost most
but learning the tools of the trade will
only help your chances because you'll
need more than bullets if you're going
to make it out
[Music]
alive I am playing the out of that game
dude that looks terrifying looks amazing
that's like a turn all the lights off
and have an extra pair of pants next to
you kind of game and I'm so excited it's
like Resident Evil but with hauntings
and a little bit better it's like
Resident Evil Outlast and last of us all
had a baby yeah yeah yeah it just looks
uh incredible uncomfortable I I I I kind
of don't know if I want to sit through
that look
PT no okay but this you at least get a
gun sometimes you not listen to the but
you the fact is is you can kill the
things but you have to make sure they're
dead that's the thing that's going to
get me that right
there I'm going forget to burn the
bodies that one
time let just B that's just common sense
if you kill someone you burn their body
always double tap yeah always always
double tap how't you guys ever killed
someone before it's pretty simple you
just burn it afterwards I'm not supposed
to talk that's why I always carry a
gallon of gasoline around me my truck
you never know if you might hit someone
on the
road what's wrong with you
guys I used it to fill up my car I'm
sorry you should probably refill it
that's so it's so dumb to murder
whatever it's murder K that's just
expensive but as far as this game goes
it's going to be one hell of a [__]
Thrill Ride for sure plus the main guy
looks pretty cool mhm that's true looks
like a cool detective very true I love
the trailer itself it had like that
Grindhouse type of vibe to it yeah that
was really cool cool throwback Vibe yeah
you know these game trailers are
sometimes a lot better than movie
trailers I think they're much better in
general General I think they give you
more to go off of because it's more of a
an indepth you know it's you have to
cooperate with it and it tries to get
you to get you because it's an
investment when you go to see a movie
it's like 10 bucks to go see a movie and
it's like an hour out of your day where
you have this it's like 60 bucks and you
have hours of your time that you have to
dedicate to this thing they have to make
sure that you are going to get involved
that's all great yeah coming to the back
to the channel okay uh if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real reject I agree with it thank you
yeah that's wonderful Alysa if uh you
want to subscribe to Alyssa's Channel
Alyssa be crazy over here Dan has a
gaming channel that's cyber channel
right over here so yeah subscribe to all
three we have [__] and you'll get
updated about our [__] every time one of
our new shits are
out Christian Loria hey guys keep up the
good work can I get a shout out
Christian Longoria Longoria another name
for this
guy
Longoria Christian because it's blessed
by Jesus
there was a there was a period of time
where I thought maybe once maybe once
there would be no reference to your dick
no that's not going to be true it's
never going to be true what are you dumb
you
dick [__] that one up take two what are
you dumb you
dick you're going to regret doing that
when this guy is going to release his
Evil Within shut up shut up
Nasco
matus that hello sounds terrifying was
someone was like the Nasco motus is
coming I be like what the what kind of
giant bug creatur
is the town is completely empty hey man
cool Channel by the way can I get a
shout out greetings from
Argentina Argentina dude Argentina the
you French guys are
awesome Nasco that's a guy's name I
don't have words anymore that's awesome
that you're sh out from Argentina all
the way over there takes
effort I would like to buy
Hamburger we are going to kick and
bison's ass that was a street fighter
but lasasco seriously Argentina you guys
speak Argentinian I
know we're moving on M us Ryan you
[__] [__]
shout me the [__] out if it don't if you
don't shout me out it means you have a
small penis LOL trip okay well huh I'm
shouting you out because I don't have a
small penis I'll have you know it is
average sized but I like to call it long
names to make it feel better about
itself hey we a breakthrough gosh you
said that little mar22 that's another
name for a when I'm being real with my
penis when you're being real yeah little
mar22 this is the 22nd penis I've had to
get
I
I just have no words anymore I've tried
all kinds of ethnic penises and so far
this one's the best what is it
Irish Irish and
Italian it's a
hybrid and the penis is just the right
size you don't want to be too big could
hurt a
girl that's that's little Mar 22 talking
right now not not in the little Mar 22
this little Mar he's speaking the truth
he's speaking the truth okay anyway guys
it's been fun hanging
out um join us next time let's hang out
later we'll get some nachos someone said
nachos nachos are the
best I get really excited about nachos
cuz it's cheese on chips someone said
nachos